savez-vous
identifier ce bruit
de fin août jusqu'à octobre le cerf se
fait entendre à la nuit tombée il s'agit
du brame un cri facilement
reconnaissable durant la période de
reproduction du service d alors ce soir
on a eu vraiment beaucoup de chance
parce que
on a donc on est vraiment resté sur sur
un chemin communal et à côté de nous on
a pu entendre pas mal de cerfs il y en
avait trois quatre qui bramait à ses
proches on a pu
identifier plusieurs brame il y avait
notamment le un brame de longueur c'est
celui qui
est long à langoureux
c'est celui qui va vraiment
asseoir le cerf sur sur sa place
autour du de cette place il va y avoir
toutes les biches qui vont gravité mais
pour Solène le plus important c'est de
faire de la pédagogie avec les personnes
présentes grâce à des quiz des photos ou
encore des ossements
euh bah que le que les mygales ça
faisait des chaussettes aussi que les
servent aller dans les propriétés
privées c'était super cela nous a bien
expliqué déjà l'environnement ce qu'on
allait voir le brame du cerf mais
c'était très sympa ouais marcher dans la
nuit comme ça sans lumière c'est en fait
on sait pas les mêmes sens qui qui
travaillent et du coup c'est c'est
vraiment sympa si vous souhaitez
découvrir le brame du cerf attention il
y a quelques règles à respecter ne vous
écartez pas des chemins forestiers
autorisés soyez le plus discret possible
sans lumière et ne cherchez pas à vous
approcher des animaux le brame est avant
tout une période d'écoute